bonjour à tous
nous pouvons débuter président
merci merci cher Micheline je vérifie
simplement que mon micro soit bien
ouvert mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues nous poursuivons ce matin à
nos travaux donc cadre de notre étude
sur territoriale on les rapporteurs sont
Catherine Concorde et Guillaume
Chevrollier est éventuellement à
saint-pierre-et-miquant je participe à
cette réunion en visioconférence et je
vous prie évidemment de mon excuser je
laisserai donc la vie présidente
Michelin de près le soin de présider la
suite de cette réunion avant lui
redonner le micro et puis présente
j'aurais moi plus tard une question à
poser à CMA-CGM concernant
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je voudrais
d'abord saluer les intervenants de la
société c'est ma CGM groupe que nous
avons eu l'occasion d'auditionner à
plusieurs reprises dans les
problématiques de liaison commerciale et
de DSR sont primordiales et omniprées
dans nos réflexions avec la présente
audition nous allons pouvoir examiner
des questions vitales pour nos outre-mer
que son entre autres la continuité
maritime le transport des marchandises
ou le coût du fret nous accueillons en
été ce matin monsieur Grégory ne force
un directeur central des lignes
maritimes accompagné de Madame Céline
serre directrice de cabinet monsieur
Cédric tlemcy télécharger des relations
institutionnelles par avance mesdames
messieurs merci pas de vous éclairages
et de vous suggestions pour renforcer la
continuité non seulement entre
l'hexagone et nos outre-mer mais
également au sein de chaque territoire
mais entre les outre-mer eux-mêmes c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre vision sur ce
sujet au fil de nos auditions nous
constatons en effet une très forte
aspiration générale à la mobilité avec
globalement et déficit d'offres dans ce
domaine c'est pourquoi nous comptons sur
nos rapporteur pour faire la lumière sur
les freins mais aussi sur les
perspectives dans ce domaine
merci à toi merci Président mes chers
collègues mesdames messieurs je vous
remercie en effet vivement pour votre
disponibilité votre présence ce matin au
palais du Luxembourg vous allez avoir la
parole afin de présenter vos
observations sur la trame qui vous a été
transmise par nos rapports mais vous
pourrez aussi nous transmettre des
éléments
ultérieurs man par écrit ensuite je
laisserai la parole à nous rapporter
madame Catherine Concorde et monsieur
Guillaume chevrolier et puis ce sera le
tour des collègues présentes Marie-Laure
donc monsieur Grégory Forcin directeur
central des lignes maritimes vous avez
la parole pour une dizaine de minutes
écoutez merci infiniment de nous avoir
permis de nous exprimer aujourd'hui et
pour cette audition
par rapport à cette audition j'aimerais
déjà démarrer cette cette audition en
vous mentionnant quand même que c'est
macgm nous sommes continuons aujourd'hui
de nous de nous développer c'est un
groupe de 150 000 collaborateurs
maintenant aujourd'hui
un acteur mondial de la logistique et du
transport avec 450 agences dans 160 pays
on fait aujourd'hui l'équivalent de 22
millions de VP équivalent en 20 pieds de
conteneurs
ça c'est nos chiffres de 2021
584 navires
commerciaux aujourd'hui c'est 275 lignes
maritimes donc présent bien sûr surtout
le tous les continents et puis également
l'exploitation de 50 terminaux
portuaires et dernièrement une division
aérienne qui vient d'être lancée c'est
même assez GMR cargo uniquement
concentré sur le fratérien qui a démarré
en 2021 et qui aujourd'hui est en train
de se développer nous sommes nous avons
commencé avec 6 avions et nous en avoir
12 donc une société qui continue de se
développer
par rapport
à cette audition je voulais je voulais
vous présenter
ce que CMA CGM aujourd'hui offre en
termes de continuité territoriale sur
les outre-mer on a trois cartes à vous à
vous à vous afficher aujourd'hui la
première
c'est pour vous expliquer il y a pas mal
de traits je vais essayer d'être assez
concis
c'est pour vous expliquer un petit peu
le maillage de CMA-CGM sur sur les
outre-mer ici on se concentre
essentiellement sur le bassin Atlantique
avec les Antilles et la Guyane française
ou en fait nous expliquons que nous
sommes présents essentiellement au
départ d'Europe que ce soit du
Nord-Europe et de Méditerranée vers vers
les Antilles et vers la Guyane et idem
depuis les Antilles et depuis la Guyane
nous avons également un maillage très
intéressant en Caraïbes vous pouvez voir
toutes les interconnexions qui existent
aujourd'hui à travers la grande Caraïbe
depuis Kingston en Jamaïque depuis la
République Dominicaine depuis Puerto
Rico vers le plateau d'aiguillages en
passant par les Antilles donc on a à la
fois la possibilité aujourd'hui d'offrir
des services de longue haul qu'on
appelle chez nous de trajet longs et
également des trajets courts pour
approvisionner aux besoins nos
importateurs et pour offrir également
des solutions d'exportation à la fois en
sortie des Antilles en sortie de Guyane
je vous montre cette carte parce que
souvent on est on illustre un peu mal
notre notre secteur et nos réseaux
surtout sur les outre-mer il y a pas que
nos services de métropole il y a
également des services aujourd'hui intra
régionaux qu'on a pu développer et j'en
parlerai un peu plus
ultérieurement il y a deuxième carte que
je voulais vous illustrer également
deuxième voilà c'est le bassin Océan
Indien donc après avoir fait le bassin
Atlantique vous montrer également notre
présence en océan Indien donc
essentiellement sur de deux départements
d'outre-mer donc qui sont la Réunion et
Mayotte nous avons des services au
départ d'Europe mais pas que d'Europe 1
et au départ d'Asie en direct sur la
Réunion et en transbordement sur Mayotte
nous sommes évidemment toutes les
semaines à Mayotte toutes les semaines à
la réunion nous avons des services qui
sont plutôt rapides avec des
partenariats que nous avons fait avec
d'autres compagnies maritimes nous
exploitons ces services maintenant
depuis un grand nombre d'années ces
services en direct sur la réunion nous
sommes depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant en direct du Havre en direct
de fosse vers la Réunion et idem sur sur
Mayotte avec un transbordement et enfin
vous voyez également en océan Indien on
a créé également des maillages pour
pouvoir relier par exemple la Réunion à
Mayotte et pour pouvoir également avoir
la possibilité pour l'importateur et
pour l'exportateur réunionnais au
Mahorais de pouvoir importer exporter
depuis Madagascar de pouvoir le faire
aussi depuis l'Afrique du Sud vous voyez
les liens rouges on vous transmettra
évidemment cette cartographie
elles sont disponibles également sur
notre site web mais on voulait on
voulait montrera et on vous les
échangera et ça vous permet quand même
de voir les possibilités
d'acheminement du de la marchandise
également l'Inde que j'ai oublié de vous
mentionner où on fait également de
l'importation de produits de bâtiments
par exemple et de matière première la
troisième carte pour vous illustrer
également la présence du groupe et la
continuité
territoriale entre la métropole et les
îles du Pacifique entre donc le Havre
par exemple ici que vous voyez mais pas
que Dunkerque aussi sur
papete et Nouméa papeter pour la
Polynésie et puis Nouméa pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie nous avons un service
qui existe depuis je crois plus de 25
ans maintenant qui s'appelle le pad qui
offre cette solution et la nouveauté
depuis l'an dernier et en 2022 c'est que
ce service est toutes les semaines il y
a une fréquence hebdomadaire il avait
une fréquence plutôt tous les 15 jours
auparavant on a décidé de renforcer
notre fréquence et d'offrir un service
toutes les semaines aux importateurs et
aux exportateurs de Tahiti et de Nouméa
vous avez également des connexions qui
sont possibles en sortie d'Asie de Chine
que nous relions à travers la
Nouvelle-Zélande et ensuite on recharge
sur des navires de plus petites capacité
sur Tahiti et sur Nouméa voilà ça c'est
pour vous présenter quand même le
service les services aujourd'hui de
CMA-CGM et les couvertures portuaires
que nous faisons aujourd'hui que nous
offrons à l'ensemble de notre clientèle
et pour évidemment nos compatriotes dans
les dans les territoires
je vous remercie je vais essayer la
parole à Madame Céline serre directrice
du cabinet
ou pas
comment vous souhaitez qu'on
s'organise parce que vous avez vous a
laissé 10 minutes pour pouvoir faire une
présentation et puis après
on passera donc on nous disions les
trois invités et puis après ce sont les
rapporteurs qui posent des questions
vous voulez ajouter
quelque chose Cédric je voulais ajouter
quelque chose
si vous avez quelque chose à rajouter
oui après globalement je vais juste
peut-être pas recommencer jusqu'à dis
monsieur monsieur fourcin voilà c'est
des cartes qui montent bien qu'on
œuvre à la fois pour la continuité
territoriale et pour le mariage régional
voilà donc c'est je pense que c'est
carte était plutôt parlante pour vous
montrer la situation et nous offre voilà
donc ça après il y aura peut-être plus
de détails si vous voulez sur tout ce
qui pourrait être fait en connexion là
on a vraiment
présenté ce qui se fait en direct et
voilà après il y a de multiples
combinaisons possibles mais on essayait
d'être assez succinct sur notre offre
[Musique]
il y a eu aussi des hausses de taux sur
tous les marchés mondiaux qui ont été
notamment expliqués par
la hausse très forte de la demande
également par des phénomènes de
congestion portuaire très fort sur tous
les marchés globaux le groupe CMA-CGM a
protégé les territoires d'outre-mer
notamment en premièrement gelant les
taux de fret ça c'était en mai 2021 donc
les taux de retraite spot et
deuxièmement à partir du 1er août 2022
avec une baisse de 750 euros par
conteneur de 40 pieds soit 375 euros
également par content de 20 pieds pour
l'ensemble des importations à
destinations des Outre-mer donc ça ce
sont des gestes concrets qui ont avaient
pour but d'améliorer enfin de maintenir
la qualité de la de la desserte pour les
outre-mer et la compétitivité des
services
donc quand on voit tout cela il y a
aussi un engagement au quotidien pour
les territoires sur place on l'a vu
notamment dans le développement
économique de l'Innovation avec
l'ouverture de The Box un incubateur de
start-up de cm1gm donc la première
ouverture a été faite à Marseille
ensuite il y a une ouverture qui a été
faite donc en Guadeloupe la dernière
incubateur pour venir au soutien de
l'innovation dans les territoires
et il y a également dans le cadre de The
Box l'ouverture d'un incubateur social
le phare donc c'est il y a la Fondation
CMA CGM qui est présidé partenaires à la
DCI et dans le cadre de cette fondation
il y a un incubateur social qui
s'appelle le phare et qui a pu ouvrir
également en Guadeloupe pour accueillir
des projets de startup social donc
quatre startups sont désormais incubés
en Guadeloupe à cet effet donc cela
démontre que non seulement il y a une
continuité territoriale du groupe CMA
CGM entre l'hexagone et les territoires
mais également aussi un engagement au
quotidien pour le développement des
territoires et donc qui démontre
finalement une présence forte du groupe
et un soutien fort du groupe à
l'ensemble de ces territoires
c'est ce qu'on peut dire en préambule
je vous remercie je vais passer la
parole à Madame Catherine Concorde
oui bonjour à tous bonjour président
bonjour Micheline bonjour
à nos interlocuteurs
forcément la CM à CGM joue un rôle très
important puisque c'est via ce réseau
que sont acheminés l'essentiel de la
consommation
des pays placés en pacifiques et dans le
bassin Atlantique Pacifique
océan Indien et
la CMA CGM et aujourd'hui quasiment en
monopole en fait pour le bassin que je
connais le mieux c'est-à-dire le bassin
Atlantique
avez-vous
conscience de l'effet fret du coup du
fret sur le prix des marchandises c'est
une question
je vous remercie même cancan
pour répondre à votre question
précisément par rapport à notre position
que vous mentionnez de monopole nous ne
sommes pas en monopole sur sur le bassin
Atlantique et aux Antilles nous avons
des concurrents aux Antilles nous sommes
pas seuls nous travaillons avec des
concurrents donc on peut les mentionner
j'ai pas de problème on avait merde ce
qui était
inconcurent on a citerait qui est
également un concurrent on a la Soret
d'homme qui sont également des
concurrents marrette est également
présent donc on a une concurrence sur
sur les Antilles par rapport
c'est quasi monopole
juste pour vous vous mentionner par
rapport au prix du fret donc
2021 et 2022 ont été des années
absolument exceptionnel en termes de de
demande
liée essentiellement à la consommation
et à l'accélération de la consommation
avec le covid on l'a tous vécu
mais ce que je voulais vous dire Madame
Concorde c'est que les territoires
d'outre-mer
vous croyez ou pas mais ils ont été
protégés protégés parce que quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui la structure des
importations qui sont faites dans nos
territoires ces territoires on importe à
peu près 70 à 80% des volumes d'Europe
ce qui s'est passé avec l'explosion des
prix de fret en sortie d'Asie correspond
plutôt à des fraises qui sortaient
d'Asie vers l'Amérique du Nord vers
l'Amérique du Sud vers l'Europe vers les
États-Unis on n'a pas vu ce phénomène
d'augmentation de prix pendant ces deux
années sur les territoires d'outre-mer
les territoires d'outre-mer si vous ne
peut me permettre ont été protégés de
cette phase de croisse enfin
d'augmentation des taux de fret c'est la
compétition c'est le manque d'espace qui
a créé cette bulle de de au niveau des
taux de fret mais qui fait que quand
même
pour importer en Guadeloupe pour
importer en Martinique ou pour importer
dans un territoire en outre-mer on a une
protection parce que quand vous
regarderez ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui et
ce qu'on importe aujourd'hui dans les
territoires d'outre-mer on importe
massivement en sortie d'Europe et les
tarifs n'ont pas bougé en sortie
d'Europe comme la mentionné monsieur
climsik ils ont été gelés à partir de
mai 2021 et depuis le 31 le 1er août
pardon 2022 le groupe seul a décidé de
faire une aide pour le pouvoir d'achat
vers tous les territoires et
départements d'outre-mer de 750 euros
par 40 pieds ça c'est valable pendant un
an donc cet effort là il est consenti
par le groupe il est consenti par ses
macgm nous n'avons pas de concurrent qui
a fait la même chose personne
aujourd'hui
suite à cette annonce et nous allons
continuer donc à faire
c'est peut-être pour le pouvoir d'achat
pour justement
voir et espérer que à destination on
puisse pour le panier de la ménagère
pour le panier du consommateur voir une
baisse du prix du prix de vente ou du
prix d'achat des produits notamment les
produits de première nécessité et cette
et cet engagement il a été fait quand
même depuis le premier août et il va
durer jusqu'au 31 juillet 2023 donc pour
nous sur les départements et territoires
d'outre-mer nous n'approns pas vu cette
explosion des taux de fraise bien au
contraire cette explosion des taux de
fret elle s'est passé essentiellement
sur les marchés comme on appelle chez
nous est ouest entre l'Asie l'Europe
l'Asie les États-Unis et
l'Amérique latine également mais pas sur
les territoires et départements
d'outre-mer
alors je me permets de reprendre la
parole pour préciser ma question je
parlais pas de la période covid pour
vous situer qui je suis je participe à
toutes les réunions de l'epmr à toutes
les réunions avec la CMA CGM y compris à
la réception récente de rodolsa a dit en
Martinique donc la repartition de qui
fait quoi la concurrence rassurez-vous
je connais ça sur le bout des ongles et
c'est pourquoi j'ai bien parlé de quasi
monopole donc je ne reviens pas sur ça
ce sont des données que je connais et
que j'alimente régulièrement quand elle
m'a pas anticipation dans toutes les
réunions de réflexion sur les prix etc
donc je répète est-ce ma question
dans la composition de prix de
marchandises arrivé dans nos territoires
et encore une fois très humblement je me
contente de parler de la zone atlantique
que je connais mieux
Martinique Guadeloupe Guyane
êtes-vous conscient de la part du frais
dans la composition du prix je ne parle
pas de la remise de 700 euros on connaît
tout ça il y a pas de problème la part
du fait mais aussi certains calculs
qu'ils sont faits
en volume et pas en poids en volume et
pas en valeur et que certains
distributeurs voudraient voir changer
alors entrer dans les détails techniques
tout le reste rassurez-vous la remise de
700 euros la couverture pendant le covid
je connais pas au coeur vous parlez
l'initié je suis là pour rentrer dans le
cœur du moteur de la composition de prix
et dans la part du fret dans la
marchandise livrée en Martinique et d'un
certain nombre de spécificités
compte tenu des valeurs et de
l'application de ces tarifs de frais sur
les valeurs
alors pour répondre à votre question le
la part du prix du fret dans la valeur
de la marchandise une fois vendue en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe pour vous
donner un exemple on entre 6 à 8 %
. voilà donc évidemment ça va dépendre
après de la valeur du produit un
conteneur de pâtes ou un conteneur de
champagne n'a pas la même valeur à la
vente mais aujourd'hui nous nos tarif de
fret il s'applique de la même manière
que vous envoyez un conteneur de pâtes
ou un conteneur de de champagne nous
n'avons pas la maîtrise aujourd'hui de
la marchandise qui va dans les
conteneurs et c'est pas nous aujourd'hui
qui organisons cette cette logistique si
vous voulez donc nous aujourd'hui ce que
on peut vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que
sur les ventes aujourd'hui des produits
en Martinique en Guadeloupe la part du
transport maritime est faible d'ailleurs
je pense que les autorités de la
concurrence et le rapport des autorités
de la concurrence qui a été fait en 2019
le montre je pense qu'il a été ce point
était soulevé et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
et on en est là pour aujourd'hui pour en
parler en tout cas nous pour en ce qui
concerne le prix du transport maritime
vous avez qu'il y a trois variables sur
le transfert une variable sur le
transport maritime qui a le carburant
aujourd'hui puisqu'on subit aujourd'hui
le coût d'achat du carburant quand le
fret quand le pétrole monte
malheureusement on doit acheter du
pétrole cher quand il baisse et ben on
en profit également mais le consommateur
en profite puisque on a un système
aujourd'hui un de
bunker adjustement de bave qu'on appelle
dans le jargon chez nous qu'on révise
tous les trimestres d'ailleurs à ce
sujet la bunker adjustement de facteur
sur les Antilles elle va quand même
baisser de près de 300 euros sur un 40
pieds entre décembre 2022 et janvier 23
donc ça c'est effectivement c'est c'est
mécanique puisque le pétrole a un petit
peu diminué même si aujourd'hui il reste
assez stable donc aujourd'hui on peut
nous aujourd'hui dire que
aujourd'hui c'est 6 à 8% de la valeur du
produit vendu aux Antilles
alors ce sera un
matériez-vous prêt à
participer à une réflexion avec les
distributeurs avec l'État sur la prise
en charge de la durée en valeur
marchandise sur le calcul du prix je
vous donne un exemple
6% appliqués à des
téléphones je prenne map comme ça iPhone
qui sont un peu plus de 1000 euros en
Martinique et donc réservé à une
certaine élite élite au pouvoir d'achat
et si vous en appliqués effectivement à
un conseiller de pâte on voit bien que
la différence
de pacte du coup
marchandisivré est totalement différent
les distributeurs et les réflexions en
cours souhaiteraient en tout cas que
nous puissions travailler de manière
très large à une révision des modes de
calcul de l'application
qui tiennent davantage compte de la
valeur
écoutez madame Cancun nous on est prêt à
participer à des tables rondes des
réflexions avec vous pour pour essayer
de d'avancer dans cette direction
j'ai envie de vous dire que la réponse
elle vient pas elle provient pas de
cma-cm et des transporteurs maritimes je
pense qu'il faut regarder tout tout un
ensemble de choses il y a vous
mentionnez le iPhone ou le téléphone le
smartphone c'est une bonne c'est un bon
exemple
l'octroi de mer aujourd'hui sur ce type
d'appareil
quasiment à zéro
l'octroi de mer sur des marchandises
alimentaires nécessaires et produits de
première nécessité sont importants dans
certains territoires notamment en
Martinique ou en Guadeloupe est-ce qu'on
peut pas également regarder tout ce
prixme parce que je pense que ok il y a
une valeur marchande à regarder mais il
faut qu'on regarde également lorsque le
produit est vendu en Guadeloupe ou en
Martinique et également un facteur
octobre mère qui joue également sur le
prix de vente du produit et qu'on peut
pas négliger voilà c'est simplement que
une réflexion que je voulais avoir
auprès de auprès de vous je sais que
c'est une discussion qu'on doit avoir
mais quand même c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui
Catherine tu as tu n'as plus d'autres
questions
non juste pour
remercier que c'est ma CGM serait prêt à
accepter l'invitation à participer à
cette réflexion et simplement dire que
sur beaucoup de produits de première
nécessité
l'octobre
ne serait-ce que dans dans le pays qui
que je connais le mieux c'est-à-dire la
Martinique et qu'il faut pas oublier je
confie dessus que l'octoie de merde
malheureusement je le regrette parce que
pour moi c'est une situation qui est
unique et totalement paradoxale c'est
l'Octo admire qui contribue à compléter
le financement des budgets des communes
donc si l'état dit nous allons donner
une DGF qui correspondent aux calculs
qui sont faits en France métropolitaine
aux communes et donc pouvoir baisser
leur poids de mer je vote à 10 mai mais
pour l'instant c'est 7h toi de merde qui
malheureusement malheureusement
contribue au budget de fonctionnement
des communes autrement dit c'est le
Martiniquais directement après le
Martiniquais les autres les autres
peuples de la vie d'outre-mer qui paye
directement de sa poche des budgets de
fonctionnement de commune c'est comme si
on mettait une taxe douanière à l'entrée
de Paris ou alors qui de Bondo qui
devrait contribuer au budget des
communes donc je sais que l'octoine
mairie souvent décrié qu'on le pose du
doigt mais il faut pas le faire dans le
sens de dire il faut que la collectivité
baisse le tarif d'emploi de merde parce
que la conséquence c'est que les
communes n'auront pas de quoi payer leur
budget leur budget de fonctionnement
donc c'est une démarche globale
qu'il faut avoir mais je tiens aussi à
cette proposition qui est faite de
travailler sur les notions de valeur
produit en banquier et une meilleure
perruquation en matière de fête je vous
remercie merci chers collègues je vais
laisser la parole à Guillaume
Chevrollier
spécifique aux outre-mer ou est-ce que
ça peut être même plus faible encore
dans certains territoires en fonction du
stratégie que vous pourriez avoir de
développement ou c'est vraiment une
orientation politique de privilégier les
territoires ultramarins parce que vous
êtes une entreprise dont le siège social
est à Marseille puisque voilà c'est
l'approche prix nous dans nos travaux et
dans ce lien entre la métropole et les
territoires
ultramarins et de d'assurer ce continuum
pour favoriser les échanges humains bien
sûr mais aussi des échanges matériels au
travers de vous votre transport maritime
c'est quand même le facteur prix plus ce
sera compétitif et abordable plus on
crée du flux et plus on densifie les
relations et on conforte les liens entre
voilà la métropole et les territoires
ultramants et donc
ma question c'est vraiment c'est quel
facteur supplémentaires on peut
sur quel facteur supplémentaires on peut
agir pour avoir des prix de plus en plus
compétitifs
vis-à-vis de nos territoires ultramarins
que ce soit l'Atlantique et le Pacifique
je vous remercie monsieur sénateur
pour essayer de vous apporter des un peu
d'éclairage par rapport à votre question
sur les territoires et départements
d'outre-mer je oui nous avons une
politique de tarif
on va pas dire avantageuse bien sûr mais
qui est loin de ce que nous avons fait
en sortie d'Asie vers d'autres
territoires américains ou ou
latino-américain ou ou même au nord
européen donc aujourd'hui comme je le
disais on prend en bulle la part du fret
aujourd'hui elle est faible dans le prix
de vente et nos taux de fret aujourd'hui
si on fait une moyenne aujourd'hui notre
eaux de fraise qu'on fait depuis 5 ans
ou 10 ans elle est stagne elle ne bouge
pas elle ne monte pas donc aujourd'hui
le fret qu'on vend que ce soit pour les
Antilles ou pour les autres départements
d'outre-mer il va pas varier donc le
prix de vente normalement il doit pas
varier si nous en tout cas notre prix de
notre prix de transport il bouge pas
permettez-moi quand même de
pouvoir vous donner quelques éclairages
quand on envoie un bateau quand même
entre Le Havre et pape
pour faire tourner une ligne comme ça il
faut 13 navires
donc si vous voulez l'investissement de
départ est important et pour en plus de
ça s'il faut continuer d'être vers
de faire attention quand même à nos
rejets de CO2 et d'avoir des navires
modernes bien évidemment on a une
politique d'investissement qui est
obligatoire pour maintenir nos
équipements
à niveau
idem pour les Antilles
idem pour la Guyane idem pour la Réunion
idem finalement pour les départements et
territoires d'outre-mer donc finalement
on a besoin d'être compétitif mais aussi
on a également besoin d'investir et de
continuer à avoir une flotte moderne qui
finalement nous oblige également à
investir
par rapport à ce que vous disiez sur les
prix
moi j'ai envie de vous demander est-ce
qu'on peut pas à travers nos
rayons notre rayonnement aujourd'hui que
ce soit en océan Indien aux Antilles et
même en Pacifique est-ce qu'on peut pas
travailler ensemble pour essayer
de faire un peu plus de nier sourcing
qu'on appelle chez nous et de faire un
peu plus d'aller chercher aujourd'hui
des possibilités d'emporter d'ailleurs
et de ne pas avoir ce réflexe de
toujours importer de métropole où on
sait qu'on a des transit time des
transits longs et des coups de frais
peut-être qui sont peut-être un peu
chers par rapport à la valeur qui est
transportée est-ce qu'on peut pas par
exemple acheter des pommes de terre
je vous dis n'importe quoi à Cuba et les
importer aux Antilles
est-ce qu'on peut pas pourquoi pas
acheter du riz ou un peu plus de manière
plus proche et ce qu'on peut pas
importer des salades du Costa Rica
au lieu de les importer de métropole
c'est également cette réflexion qu'il
faut qu'on ait pour que le consommateur
et l'importateur aujourd'hui s'il veut
faire une baisse au niveau de son prix
de vente il est obligé de regarder par
sur ce nier sur signe sur ce cette
régionalisation des flux et où je vais
me sourcer parce que finalement
l'approvisionnement si on reste toujours
dans un schéma Le Havre Tahiti Le Havre
Guadeloupe Le Havre Martinique nous on
pourra pas rapprocher les mers
malheureusement et on aura toujours
ces distances qui qui sépareront nos
compatriotes dans dans les territoires
d'outre-mer et la métropole donc moi
j'invite tous les acteurs à réfléchir à
ce sourcing plus proche et nous c'est
même assez j'aime on est prêt également
à aller démarcher avec les importateurs
aider les importateurs locaux dans les
pays où on produit par exemple ma salade
au Costa Rica par exemple des du papier
des emballages en Colombie ou d'autres
possibilités et on est prêt à
accompagner les importateurs pour aider
ces gens à trouver les vecteurs et les
réseaux afin de afin de pouvoir importer
de manière plus courte et de manière
peut-être moins élevée c'est je pense
qu'il est important aujourd'hui de
regarder ces possibilités c'est vraiment
je pense un critère très important on
parle également du digital du numérique
je pense qu'il faut développer le
e-commerce dans les développe dans les
départements les territoires d'outre-mer
je pense que aujourd'hui en métropole on
peut importer ce qu'on veut très
rapidement par le e-commerce je ne pense
pas que ça puisse se faire aussi
facilement aussi rapidement dans les
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
je pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'il y ait
également cette
cette volonté de vouloir avancer
voilà pour pour répondre à votre
question monsieur sénateur
merci en réaction à vos propos on a le
sujet de la continuité territoriale il y
a l'hexagone et les territoires
ultramarins mais après il y a également
entre territoires ultramarins et le coup
par exemple on nous indique le coût
entre par exemple la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique peut être parfois très élevé
parfois plus élevé que de que de passer
de métropole le prix du fait
vous pouvez nous donner par rapport à ça
que si vous aviez des éléments à nous
fournir monsieur je serai vraiment ravi
de les recevoir parce que je
j'ose pas imaginer que on fasse payer un
frais plus cher entre la Martinique et à
la Guadeloupe ou entre la Guadeloupe et
la Martinique comparé un fret entre la
métropole et les Antilles mais c'est à
vérifier mais j'aimerais bien avoir
quand même là dessus des des éléments si
vous voulez parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pas du tout ce qu'on applique pas du
tout
aujourd'hui
les frais qui sont qui sont faits entre
la métropole et la Martinique et le la
Guadeloupe sont bien plus importants
comparé à un fret entre la Guadeloupe et
la Martinique
mais les échanges sont très faibles
mais on a également des échanges entre
les entiers et la Guyane on a des
services également spécialisés dans sur
ce sur ces solutions on a même j'ai
envie de vous le dire et j'en suis j'en
suis très fier grâce aux équipes et
grâce également à nos équipes en Guyane
et à tous nos collègues guyanais on va
ouvrir à partir du 22 mars une escale à
Saint-Laurent de maronis nous allons
aller à Saint-Laurent de maronis le 22
mars
c'est c'est nouveau
saint-laurent-de-maroni c'est l'ouest de
la Guyane on sait qu'il y a un
développement important au niveau
démographique on sait qu'il y a des
entreprises qui s'installent on sait
qu'il y a
des importations qu'on pourrait passer
par Saint Laurent le problème c'est que
Saint-Laurent de Maroni c'est un port
fluvial et il y a 4 mètres d'eau
voilà donc on a on sait qu'on a des
contraintes portuaires compliquées mais
on va essayer de le faire sachant qu'en
Guyane déjà aujourd'hui en Guyane a
dégrade des cannes quand vous voulez
escaler vous n'avez que 6 mètres 52 et
vous travaillez avec des grues de bord
vous n'avez pas d'infrastructures
portières vous n'avez pas de portique
vous n'avez pas de grue donc on va on va
faire cette première escale à
saint-laurent-de-maronis et on va
pouvoir donc développer développer ce
lien régional et même pouvoir aller
offrir une solution à l'importateur
guyanais dans l'Ouest guyanais au lieu
de faire du camion entre Cayenne et
Saint-Laurent le Maroni il pourra
importer directement sur Saint-Laurent
ça c'est une première qu'on fait c'est
démarrage mi-mars
avec des escales tous les mois une fois
par mois donc dans la continuité je vais
laisser la parole à Marie-Laure finira
horde qui est sénateur de Guyane
merci présidente merci Monsieur fourcin
pour ce que vous venez de dire merci
pour Louise guyanet oui effectivement il
y a une démographie galopante puis en
fait Saint-Laurent deviendra très
bientôt la deuxième la première capitale
en fait puisque c'est Cayenne mais avec
sa démographie et avec toutes les
activités
c'est Laurent deviendra la capitale de
la Guyane voilà Monsieur monsieur
fourcin vous avez annoncé il y a
quelques mois une baisse de vos taux de
frais Dans le but de contribuer à
l'effort de modération des prix à la
consommation des Outre-mer un an
auparavant vous aviez pris la décision
d'appliquer un gel des taux de fret à
destination des Outre-mer je dois
reconnaître que ce sont des efforts
louables mais suscite toutefois deux
questions de ma part sans vouloir
remettre en cause votre modèle
économique devant nous croire que les
taux pratiqués auparavant étaient
excessifs ou avait été excessif
aussi je sais pas pour les autres
territoires même si je rejoins ma
collègue Catherine Concorde mais je
crois pas avoir constaté les
conséquences de vos efforts au niveau
des prix pratiqués dans les commerces
j'admets que vous n'êtes pas les mieux
placés pour m'apporter une réponse pour
cette deuxième question mais je tenais
néanmoins à l'évoquer comme la fait tout
à l'heure Catherine le panier des
ménages est très important pour nous et
on se rend compte que nos compatriotes
en tout cas nos ménagères souffrent
justement par rapport à ces tarifs voilà
ce que je vais partager avec vous et
encore une fois merci pour l'Ouest
Guyane
je vais passer la parole à Victoire
jasmin sénateur de Guadeloupe oui merci
madame la Présidente
et messieurs je ne suis pas jeune que
soyez pas là pour allonger le débat mais
j'ai entendu
faire qui pourraient privilégier
certains échanges avec la grande
Caraïbes et les Grandes Antilles
lors de l'examen de la proposition de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat en juillet
dernier je crois j'avais évoqué
justement les problématiques liées au
transport maritime et conséquences et je
crois que notre collègue rapporteur
Madame Catherine Concorde c'est
l'artiste la Martinique elle a sans
doute évoqué aussi ses problématiques là
et nous avons eu la chance de rencontrer
entre temps le PDG monsieur Rodolphe
Sade et j'ai son équipe en Guadeloupe et
il avait effectivement annoncé cette
diminution de cours qui vient d'être
évoqué par un autre collègue signatrice
cependant il y a également des
difficultés
sur la répartition alors je voudrais
savoir d'une part comment vous allez
fonctionner avec parce qu'il y a
d'autres armateurs qui ne fonctionnent
plus par exemple mais tu veux dire quoi
et c'est vous qui allez faire quasiment
tout le cabotage sur nos territoires
alors est-ce que vous vous faites un
service public un service je dirais bon
peut-être pas publiquement un service
pour les autres comment se répartir sur
comment les contenirs sont en fait quel
est le pourcentage de ce que vous leur
conseiller
comment se répartis de façon générale et
l'autre chose alors vous avez évoqué
quelque chose qui pourrait être très
intéressant par exemple faire certains
achats à Cuba et pourquoi pas dans
d'autres
îles de la Caraïbe alors je voudrais il
y a des questions de normes également
parce que bon il faudrait ce sont des
pistes qui sont intéressantes moi je
trouve que je l'avoue mais par rapport à
l'usage de certains produits
phytosanitaires par rapport à certains
pesticides je crois que bon il y a pas
toutes les normes requises
pour la France et
l'Europe et en plus il y a par rapport
aux régions ultra périphériques un
certain nombre de directives également
par rapport au pays donc là ce sont des
pistes peut-être mais les rapporteurs
devront peut-être aussi creuser dans ce
domaine là pour voir ce qui se pourrait
être
proposé voilà et la dernière question
alors lorsque j'avais posé en juillet la
question du transport parce qu'il y
avait aussi le gouvernement avait
proposé avait proposé un amendement que
j'avais refusé c'était pour le transport
et des prêts à taux zéro pour les
transporteurs de marchandises mais
c'était pour les véhicules propres pour
transférer carrément sur nos différents
territoires au niveau national le
gouvernement proposé un amendement pour
des prêt à taux zéro pour remplacer les
flottes et là j'avais évoqué les
difficultés que vous aviez à l'époque
concernant le transport des véhicules
des véhicules électriques notamment
parce que il y avait des risques
d'incendie alors quels sont les
solutions que vous avez apportées entre
temps est-ce que
cela va être possible sachant que sur
nos territoire pour le moment les
conditions sont pas réunies pour ces
véhicules propres mais comment
anticipez-vous et la situation merci
alors par rapport à votre question
madame pour la Guyane donc on est très
contents pour Saint-Laurent j'espère que
la première escale va bien se passer
et je pense que c'est le début d'une
belle aventure si on réussit à
faire à faire nos escales sans
difficulté
par rapport aux fraises et
au gel des fraises et
à l'annonce des 750 euros pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée sur la Guyane 750
euros sur un fret aujourd'hui c'est à
peu près 20% des fois sur le fret
vous pourriez me dire pourquoi on
retrouve pas cet effort sur à la vente
ensuite par contre par 40 pieds
sur la goutte sur la Guadeloupe ou sur
la Martinique c'est un peu plus c'est à
peu près 30% parce que le taux de fret
sur la Guyane c'est un peu plus cher que
sur la Guadeloupe de par la difficulté
on va dire d'aller desservir ce
territoire
donc quand même cet effort du groupe il
est il est réel il existe chaque semaine
chaque conteneur qui charge aujourd'hui
pour les départements d'outre-mer
bénéficient des 750 euros cet argent on
le donne sera belle il existe on le fait
et ça ça dure depuis déjà maintenant le
premier août donc on est maintenant au
mois de février et force cette constaté
malheureusement que on vous ne voyez pas
vous ne voyez pas de baisse
des prix de vente dans les magasins et
vous voyez noter quand même que nous en
tant qu'acteur de cette de cette baisse
c'est quand même monsieur Saad qui a
pris cette décision je rappelle que
c'est il l'a pris seul c'est nous sommes
le seul armateur à l'avoir fait
aujourd'hui on est quand même assez
frustré de voir qu'il y a pas grand
chose qui a avancé finalement et que
quand on va devoir réinjecter ces 750
euros parce que ça a une fin tout ça le
31 juillet 2023 j'aimerais que
j'aimerais pas qu'on nous dise bah on va
augmenter les prix devant parce que
finalement grâce à ses 750 euros on a pu
faire baisser les prix alors qu'ils
n'ont pas baissé donc là
est-ce que on pourrait pas également
avoir des réflexions ensemble moi j'ai
longuement discuté avec les préfets
notamment pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi aujourd'hui cette baisse onolla
voit pas
si le finalement le transport maritime
est si important si le prix du transport
maritime est déterminant aujourd'hui
dans le prix de vente d'un produit
pourquoi aujourd'hui ça se voit pas sur
le paquet de pâtes pourquoi ça se voit
pas donc c'est tout c'est toute cette
situation qui nous frustre un petit peu
aujourd'hui comme vous pour lesquels il
y a cet effort qui est fait on n'a pas
de réponse enfin en tout cas on le voit
pas et c'est malheureux si je suis
désolé de vous le dire c'est malheureux
par rapport à votre question sur sur
Mars madame
mersk il avait une allocation
aujourd'hui faisait 400 pu sur les
Antilles entre 350 et 400 il avait à peu
près 400 TG chaque semaine 400
conteneurs il a décidé de se retirer du
marché des Antilles c'est son choix je
le commenterai pas et donc nous nous
allons continuer à desservir les
Antilles et bien évidemment les clients
qui chargés avec mer ce que vont devoir
charger avec sa macgm bon les clients
qui chargent avec mer chargés aussi XMA
CGM de toute façon on a une concurrence
qui est établie c'est quand même dommage
qu'il s'en aille mais écoutez nous on
prend note de son de leur départ il
reste quand même il reste quand même si
traîne qui est là toutes les semaines il
reste également ma retraite qui est un
acteur également important pour les
Antilles et vous avez Soré d'hommes
également qui a été un acteur qui est
plus moi dans le transport de conteneur
mais plus dans le transport de vrac
donc nous on reprendra ce que faisait
merde ce qui est on sera toujours là de
toute façon
il faut répondre tout à l'heure à la
question de Monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur chevrolier c'est même assez GM
nous c'est un trait d'union l'Hexagone
les outre-mer donc on continuera à
servir les autres mères du mieux qu'on
pourra mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
s'est renforcé le Saint-Laurent je vais
vous parler à un petit peu après de ce
qu'on a développé également autour des
Antilles pour essayer de développer cet
achat plus proche de ce sorti le plus
proche on a un service qu'on a lancé il
y a deux mois maintenant qui s'appelle
le calinago qui a un nom d'ethnie
vénézuélien
ce service là aujourd'hui il permet de
se sourcer
en Guadeloupe et en Martinique depuis
tous les cuisines qui sont autour des
Antilles que ce soit évidemment Puerto
Rico mais pas que roseau la Dominique
Barbade et Antigua par exemple
toutes les semaines nous serons dans ces
ports et toutes les semaines nous irons
en Guadeloupe en Martinique donc on
offre on offrira la possibilité à un
importateur martiniquais un importateur
guadeloupéen de pouvoir se sourcer sur
ces territoires que ce soit d'un achat
de farine pour des produits de première
nécessité ce sera faisable c'est
faisable aujourd'hui on offre cette
possibilité alors je sais que c'est
difficile ou la émotionné tout à l'heure
par rapport aux normes mais je pense
qu'il faut vraiment avancer également
sur ce sur ce sur ce sujet c'est un
sujet important pourquoi je peux pas
importer des couches culottes du Guyana
et je suis en Guyane j'ai un producteur
de couches culottes un exemple qui est
au Guyana George Town je veux importer
en deux jours ou trois jours cette
marchandise je peux pas le faire
aujourd'hui si je peux le faire faut
qu'elle passe par la métropole et garder
ça
donc nous aujourd'hui et on est comme
vous on subit également cette difficulté
mais on peut pas
tout régler et par rapport au véhicules
électriques
les véhicules électriques on a réagi
très rapidement donc on a eu des
difficultés il y a des navires rouliers
de transport de véhicules électriques
ont pris feu qu'on peut couler en début
d'année 2022 il y a eu des incidents
assez graves où en fait les batteries
ont pris feu
à cause de la température en fait à
l'intérieur des cales qui fait que la
batterie a chauffé donc on continue dieu
merci on n'a pas arrêté le transport de
véhicule électrique on continue dans
l'importer toutes les semaines en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique mais on met
ça dans des conteneurs réfrigérés
les batteries on les met on les décharge
à 40% et comme ça on est sûr que on
n'aura pas de problématique
je vous remercie donc je ne vais pas
rebondir sur la problématique des normes
qui a été soulevée c'est le cheval de
bataille de la délégation et dans tous
les rapports on retrouve notamment un
rapport le rapport sur le logement
outre-mer
intègre aussi cette difficulté des
normes donc je vous rejoins ce serait
plus facile de pouvoir s'approvisionner
dans la zone dans le bassin géographique
des territoires il y a un autre aspect
qui n'a pas été soulevé mais qui ne vous
incombe pas
qui n'est pas de votre de votre ressort
ce sont les dates de péremption des
produits frais notamment en ce qu'on
appelle dans le dernier kilomètre par
exemple les produits qui arrivent à
Saint-Barthélémy se retrouve avec des
marges vraiment très limitées ce qui
peut induire beaucoup de gas d'une part
mais qui pourrait peut-être avoir aussi
une influence sur les prix puisqu'il
faut que le
distributeur puisse se retrouver donc
j'accueille avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmes votre le développement
de la ligne RK Go donc j'aurais aimé
savoir est-ce que justement il y aura
une attention particulière sur les
produits les produits alimentaires et ce
qui permettrait d'augmenter les dates de
péremption et
permettrait dans les petites lignes
entre la Guadeloupe et Saint-Barthélémy
ou Saint-Martin Saint-Barthélémy d'avoir
même s'ils arrivent par bateau mais
d'avoir une plus grande marge de
une plus grande marge de de consommation
et deuxièmement
comme on parle beaucoup des prix est-ce
que les produits évidemment les produits
par cargo risquent d'avoir un coût qui
n'est pas le coup du fret bateau et
d'essayer de trouver des solutions pour
pouvoir justement équilibrer sans vous
demander énormément d'efforts puisque
vous êtes aussi une entreprise et si
vous voulez générer des bénéfices on ne
peut pas vous demander de travailler à
perte donc essayez de trouver une
articulation permettant justement
d'avoir de ne pas trop impacter le
consommateur
merci pour cette question
les tarifs dans dans l'air pour pour
votre information un avion ça peut
transporter entre 60 et 100 tonnes à peu
près indépendants
60 tonnes un Airbus un triple un Boeing
777 c'est à peu près une centaine de
tonnes un bateau c'est entre
50000 et 100.000 tonnes
et puis
les tarifs dans l'avion c'est au kilo
nous on est plus au conteneur et dans un
conteneur vous mettez 30 tonnes au
maximum donc on est dans des échelles
totalement différentes mais vous avez
raison évidemment les DLC on en est
consciente
on peut imaginer pourquoi pas demain
venir à Saint-Barthélemy avec avec un
avion encore faudrait-il qui qu'on soit
sûr de pouvoir le remplir d'une seule
traite donc ça veut dire venir avec 60
tonnes 50 je pourrais pas venir
la taille des avions qui atterrissent à
savoir tes limites sont vraiment très
très limitées c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous disais que le transport
maritime entre Saint-Martin ou la
guadeloupeère saint-martin-les-mines
pourrait se faire mais si par exemple la
Guadeloupe était desservie par avion ce
serait peut-être plus c'est exactement
donc on propose c'était de vous dire il
y a une possibilité c'est de faire du R6
on appelle chez nous du R et après de la
mer donc de décharger avec nos avions
c'est germes cargo de la marchandise par
exemple aux Antilles en Guadeloupe et de
pouvoir ensuite l'approvisionner depuis
la Guadeloupe vers Saint-Barthélémy
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
regarder ensemble évidemment ensuite
il faut qu'on regarde avec CMA CGR cargo
les potentiels sur sur la Guadeloupe sur
le Martinique il y a déjà beaucoup de
concurrents et il faut qu'on fasse les
études et qu'on revienne bien sûr avec
des solutions
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas
encore envisagé mais on peut le regarder
c'est un prisme qu'on peut regarder donc
on va le regarder
vous avez vous n'avez rien à rajouter
Catherine tu n'as rien à rajouter oui je
vais laisser céder pour avoir de laisser
la parole au président
et laisser je lève la main effectivement
concernant la remise de 700 euros sur
les boîtes qui ne seraient pas
ressenti dans le panier de l'aménager
c'est un peu normal si vous prenez 700
euros que vous divisez par le nombre je
prends on reprend toujours l'exemple du
paquet de parfum qui est un produit de
très grande consommation consommée par
tous les ménages les moins aisés comme
les plus aisés donc un produit assez
transversal en termes de publicité
consommateur dans une dans un contenu de
40 pieds il doit avoir des milliers de
boîtes de paquet de pâtes alors lorsque
vous divisez 700 euros par des milliers
de paquets ça va faire 0,00 je sais pas
combien de zéro après la virgule donc
totalement insensible sur le prix c'est
pourquoi je reviens à mon idée il faut
travailler à ce peut-être une baisse je
ne sais pas comment les meilleurs
perruquations en matière d'application
tarif aujourd'hui faudrait certainement
privilégier un effort supplémentaire sur
les produits de première nécessité et
par exemple 0 réduction sur une boîte
qui transforme du matériel informatique
haut de gamme des
MacBook Pro à 2000 euros et iPhone de la
high tech en matière de biovisuel etc
avoir une veste de deux trois euros sur
une télévision qui coûte 1500 euros
hyper grand écran connecté j'ai envie de
dire ça n'a aucune intérêt ça n'a aucun
sens mais par contre que cette
application de cette de cette baisse
soit majoritairement pour ne pas dire
exclusivement porter sur les produits de
la grande distribution l'huile les pâtes
le riz enfin bref ce qui comporte ce qui
composent essentiellement le panier
à mon avis ce rêve plus plus percutant
et plus efficace parce que 700 euros sur
une boîte de pâtes avec des milliers de
boîtes de boîtes de pâte à l'intérieur
c'est normal
c'est là on se rejoint pas Madame
Concorde c'est la valeur de la pâte le
valeur d'un conteneur de pâtes c'est
combien c'est pas le poids c'est pas le
nombre de pattes c'est la valeur du
conteneur si la valeur d'un compteur de
pommes de terre
de pommes de terre c'est 5000 €
. on est d'accord 5000 euros j'enlève
750 euros j'ai fait baisser de combien
donc je fais 750 euros que je divise par
5000 euros donc notre effort je fais
baisser la pomme de terre de 15%
est-ce que cet effort de 15% de baisse
de la pomme de terre elle se voit dans
le rayon
je vous demande de ne pas être en mode
on est dans une discussion ne soyez pas
autant sur la défensive je n'ai rien
contre ces sujets donc on est en train
de travailler sereinement un système que
nous voudrions proposer au gouvernement
pour que les choses aillent mieux ne
soyez pas sur la défensive je ne suis
pas aussi critiquée c'est ma CGM ni de
dire ce signe de Dieu cela on est tous
entre de travailler avoir comment on
peut faire avancer des choses sinon
cette mission n'existerait pas tout ce
que vous êtes en train de me dire je
l'entends déjà à l'Opéra dans les
réunions à la CMA CGR faut bien
comprendre le sens de notre commission
on n'est pas là pour vous critiquer on
n'est pas dans un tribunal donc soyons
noués sur la défensive je dis simplement
est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen de revoir
cette baisse de 700 euros si demain
matin elle devait être prolongée on ne
sait jamais en tout cas vous donne ça a
dit quand même quelques engagements
devant nous lors de son passage
donc est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen de se
dire peut-être une augmentation
supplémentaire sur les boîtes sur les
produits de première nécessité et 0 ou
beaucoup moins sur les boîtes qui
concernent des produits sur lesquels la
baisse Dora aucun ressenti ça va pas
changer le le consommateur quelqu'un
achète une télévision haut de gamme en
1700 euros qu'elle coûte 1492 euros bon
on s'en fout voilà je le dis pour faire
simple on s'en fout mais sur un palier
de sur un côté
d'huile etc est-ce qu'il n'y a pas mieux
je résume dessus et je conclus de mieux
fléchir la baisse sur l'essentiel du
consommateur ce sont des propositions
que nous sommes offerte rassurez-vous je
ne suis pas dans un procès avec la CM1
merci Catherine donc je vais laisser la
parole au président Artano
et merci Catherine pour tes commentaires
oui pour rassurer s'il y avait besoin de
rassurer mais je suis pas persuadé il
est important pour la France d'avoir des
gros groupes de transport maritime voilà
ça c'est une étudiant qui vous le dit et
donc évidemment qui est important que la
France soit en pointe également sur ce
sujet moi je reviens d'un
séjour passionnant aux Antilles en
Martinique en Guadeloupe avec le
président Larcher on a pu voir notamment
au Grand Port Martinique de Martine de
Guadeloupe le positionnement de CMA CGM
et notamment le rire forcing je pourrais
effectivement utiliser les anglicis
enfin vous me pardonnerez je vais
essayer de parler très franco-français
donc l'approvisionnement de proximité ou
régionale et le renforcement des
positions de CMA CGN dans la région et
c'est très intéressant comme comme
stratégie ce qui impose d'ailleurs au
Grand Port Maritime de pouvoir
réinvestir et revoir leur politique
d'investissement et de développement et
y compris de mon point de vue et je l'ai
dit à la présidente du port et tout à
fait qui était sur le départ
certainement de revoir le statut du
grand port pour lui donner une vocation
un peu plus privée pour avoir des levées
de fonds notamment en termes d'emprunt
et de dettes qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui
pour permettre justement un effet de
levier plus important au côté des
opérateurs privés je pense que là il y a
un partenariat intelligent trouvé donc
le sourcing ou de l'approvisionnement
proximité moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord et sensible à ce que vous dites
monsieur Forcin d'ailleurs c'est un peu
ce que fait Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
nous on a quasiment 50% de nos
importations qui viennent d'Amérique du
Nord et 50% qui viennent qui viennent
d'Europe donc on est sur le même sur le
même état d'esprit simplement
effectivement avec les réserves évoquées
par ma collègue victoire jasmin on a
effectivement une difficulté au niveau
de certaines normes évidemment de
certains types d'emballages de certains
produits phytosanitaires de certaines
normes de constructions qui nous
imposent des produits européens et qui
évidemment vont imposer des effets de
seuil au transporteur maritimes puisque
évidemment quand vous faites du régional
vous ne faites pas l'international et
donc les effets de feuilles vous même et
c'est évident et c'est mécanique impact
immédiatement les prix les frais de
transport moi je voulais
intervenir sur sur un aspect des choses
qui sont strictement
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon il y avait et
c'est en lien d'ailleurs avec le
positionnement vous faites aujourd'hui
on Guadeloupe et c'est très intéressant
de positionnement comme comme une sorte
de hub en fait c'est comme ça que moi je
l'ai compris c'est un œuvre régional
pour pour CMA CGM qui va éclater dans la
région et vous le faites déjà à
proximité mais vous allez aussi passer
Panama et aller sur l'ouest des
États-Unis nous avons et c'est très
intéressant comme positionnement il y a
eu il y a quelques années à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon un projet de
hob maritime
où je crois d'ailleurs CMA CGM a vu être
approché par des opérateurs économiques
locaux c'est un projet de 400 millions
d'euros en gros l'idée c'était de faire
venir des navires à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon de les faire
éclater puis d'avoir des feeders après
qui partaient dans la région Boston New
York Montréal Québec de manière générale
pour aller éclater la marchandise au
niveau régional c'est un peu la
stratégie je pense que vous allez avoir
et que vous avez déjà en Guadeloupe et
au regard des bouleversements
qu'a connu le transport maritime
international quel regard vous portez
finalement sur ce positionnement là par
en particulier c'est pas une question
piège c'est simplement que quand je vois
le positionnement de CM1 on Guadeloupe
aujourd'hui CGM je me pose la question
de savoir si on a mis du noir
effectivement il y a un positionnement
ivoire qui peut avoir encore du sens
aujourd'hui ou si le projet de l'époque
je vous parle de ça maintenant il y a
quelques années c'est un projet qui
effectivement va rester au stade des
projets aussi peut présenter un intérêt
et quand on veut du par ailleurs que
CMA-CGM est partenaire au projet
neolines qui intéresse
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon puisque néoline
Adam son ambition de toucher sa
Pierre-Yves en faisant du
transatlantique et ce qui nous pose
problème dans l'archipel ce sont les
acteurs multiples sur la chaîne de
logistique et qui viennent à chaque fois
rajouter des surtout et donc on essaye
d'avoir des lignes transatlantiques qui
permettent d'avoir des touchés plus
régulières comme vous le connaissez en
Martinique en Guadeloupe et qui
réduisent ces ponts dans quel regard
vous portez sur le positionnement de sa
pyramidon au regard du projet de
l'époque et est-ce qu'il fait toujours
sens aujourd'hui au regard des
bouleversements ont connu le monde du
transport maritime international je vous
remercie
merci
le projet de hub que nous avons en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique d'ailleurs
il n'est d'une problématique que nous
avons identifié et qui va toucher
l'ensemble de l'industrie maritime qui
ne sont les nouvelles règles de l'OMI de
l'Organisation maritime internationale
en 2023 et qui vont être mises en œuvre
en 2024 autrement dit
nous allons être contraint
nous transporteurs maritime
de devoir faire plus attention à nos
rejets de CO2 et on aura parfois des
difficultés à desservir des territoires
que nous desservons aujourd'hui de
manière assez simple demain
on a c'est un peu si vous voulez comme
les nouvelles normes pour le frigidaire
et ben on va avoir la même chose pour
les navires à partir de 2024 on aura
une classification qui sera faite par
rapport au navire utilisé et par rapport
à son utilisation sur la ligne
les services sur les Antilles et sur la
Guyane seront évidemment touchés par ces
nouvelles règles
ces règles elles vont malheureusement
nous imposer de devoir revoir notre
schéma et on va être obligé d'aller
chercher des navires plus grands
donc d'investir pour pour les Antilles
et la Guyane parce que demain avec le
système Immo 23 enfin au mi-2023 on aura
des navires qui seront trop polluants en
termes de rejet de CO2 pour continuer de
d'opérer sur les Antilles et idem sur la
Guyane on a des navires de 3500evp entre
l'Europe et les Antilles on a des
navires de 2000 2200 EVP sur sur la
Guyane donc ça nous ça nous pousse ça
nous pousse à réfléchir et à devoir
trouver
des réponses et des solutions pour pour
nos clients pour nos compatriotes afin
de desservir ces territoires comme on
les dessert aujourd'hui toutes les
semaines avec un transit time tout à
fait acceptable même pour les produits
frais et d'essayer d'être évidemment
respectueux des normes de des règles de
l'ONU donc c'est c'est quand même un
déficit équilibre
on a trouvé une solution qui serait donc
de construire des navires le dernier
génération des navires de 7000 EVP qui
pourrait donc transiter donc et
décharger en Guadeloupe en Martinique
c'est à peu près la taille maximum qu'on
puisse faire pour recevoir ce type de
navire et on pourrait donc créer de la
valeur en transbordant des conteneurs
donc continuer notre importation et en
transbordant des conteneurs en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique en
transbordant des conteneurs pour le
plateau d'aiguillages et également en
transborde des conteneurs en Martinique
qui proviendra également du Nord Brésil
et également de la Caraïbe donc c'est
comme ça qu'on a défini ce concept de
hub à la fois en Guadeloupe pour
l'import et à la fois en Martinique pour
l'export qui transforme
donc ça c'est un projet qui va naître
fin 2024 début 2025 avec cette nouvelle
réglementation au mi-2023
on a ces navires seront propulsés ou LG
donc c'est une nouveauté et l'idée c'est
d'aller encore plus loin et c'est de
créer un corridor vert et d'avoir un
navire en fait qui consommerait donc qui
mettrait plus de CO2 en brûlant du
biométhane
donc le biométhane aujourd'hui est à 0,2
0 émission CO2 on est en train de
travailler un développement sur cette
filière en étant discussion actuellement
on espère finaliser et pouvoir naviguer
entre la métropole et les Antilles
avec un navire vers totalement vert donc
on espère arriver à
ce à ce but mais néanmoins le bateau
déjà de fonctionnera LNG le LG c'est 20%
de démission de CO2 en moins comparé un
bateau qui qui fonctionne au fioul
normal
par rapport à votre question sur sur
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
j'avais pas connaissance du dossier sur
ce hub
je crois que c'est ces discussions ont
eu lieu en 2016 je crois qu'il y a eu
des annonces de faites à l'époque par
par Manuel Valls je crois sur cette
possibilité de créer un hub à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon ma vision par
rapport à ce projet c'est que il serait
quand même assez difficile de pouvoir la
notion de hub c'est que il faut
massifier il faut massifier un flux qui
rentre ou un flux qui sort rouler deux
c'est encore mieux et pour pouvoir
massifier un flux si vous voulez le
faire à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
forcément vous allez devoir aller
chercher des des destinations donc
canadiennes ou américaines et
aujourd'hui
le consommateur américain ou canadien il
est un peu comme le consommateur dans
les territoires d'outre-mer il va un
service rapide direct ça veut pas dire
que si on fait du transbordement on sera
pas rapide mais ça veut dire que quand
même il y a une volonté quand même
d'aller chercher des services en direct
et la difficulté je pense pour pouvoir
mettre en place ce type de système c'est
qu'on aura une concurrence qui
continuera à être elle en direct et nous
qui comptent qui offrirait demain par
exemple un service Le Havre
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon déchargement
rechargement Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
sur Halifax qui serait moins
concurrentielle que un service qui fait
le Havre à l'IFAC en direct donc ça
évidemment il faut qu'on regarde il faut
que si vous aviez cette étude ce projet
moi je serai je serais ravi de l'étudier
de le regarder pour pour comprendre en
fait la finalité du projet et bien
m'imprégner si vous voulez des des
volumes qui étaient en jeu c'est
important
aux États-Unis il y a également une
barrière également douanière vous savez
que pour exporter des marchandises au
départ d'Europe ou de n'importe où dans
le monde vers les États-Unis vous êtes
obligé de faire une une documentation
CSA donc ça veut dire que ça imposerait
également à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon de
devoir faire cette cette obligation de
douanières donc je m'interroge
il faudrait il faudrait regarder
vraiment cette ce projet et quand t'as
le néoline évidemment et le projet donc
a été lancé ça masse et j'aime comme
vous le savez partenaire donc l'objectif
c'est de démarrer en 2025 avec ce navire
qui sera un navire ayant l'équivalent de
1200 mètres linéaires c'est à peu près
pour vous donner un ordre d'idées 260
conteneurs voilà on pourra mettre 400
véhicules à l'intérieur il fonctionnera
à voile électrique et voile c'est une
vraie une vraie innovation et on a hâte
de voir
ce navire venir à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon puisque c'est
son objectif
je vous remercie j'ai vu que notre
collègue Nassim aladdar nous a rejoint
donc je ne sais pas si elle souhaite
intervenir
il faudrait que tu actionnes
bonjour à tous c'est ce que vous
m'entendez
parfaitement Nassima
très bien bonjour et puis je profite de
l'occasion j'ai bien entendu
d'abord les engagements que nous
connaissons du groupe CMA CGM et j'avais
une question pas seulement sur le
maritime la question du Fred se pose
effectivement à la Réunion et pour
l'ensemble des
ultramarins en général et également pour
Mayotte et nous-mêmes et nous apprécions
les 750 euros d'aide nous savons que les
gens râlent beaucoup j'avais une
question pour sur l'aérien si vous m'y
autorisez vous investissez aussi
beaucoup comment voyez-vous
une aide de l'État ou de l'Europe parce
qu'il me semble que pour travailler sur
la continuité territoriale il faut à la
fois aider les compagnies aériennes et
les collectivités qui eux aideraient les
usagers et donc je défends ce principe
là vous en tant que investisseur dans
Air France comment est-ce que vous voyez
des aides de l'État et de l'Europe pour
assurer la continuité territoriale et
aussi des personnes et des marchandises
c'était une question que je voulais
poser puisque nous avons la chance
d'avoir le directeur ici alors je vous
remercie pour votre question alors je
suis vraiment pas spécialiste pour la
réponse à vos apporter sur le
partenariat et Air France par contre ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous la
filiale dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est même assez j'aime air cargo elle
est concentrée uniquement 100% pour le
fret on fait pas de transport de
passagers
on a fait des touchés sur la réunion je
crois qu'on en a fait deux on a même été
prendre des litchis de la Réunion qu'on
a apporté en métropole
c'était c'était fin d'année dernière je
crois
donc je suis pas spécialiste pour vous
répondre sur cette question et sur
comment assurer la continuité
territoriale comment l'État pourrait
participer dans cette action je suis pas
je suis désolé pour de ne pas pouvoir
vous répondre nous ce que ce qu'on
souhaite avec cette filiale évidemment
c'est de pouvoir être indépendant et
pouvoir répondre aux besoins des
importateurs notamment sur sur la
Réunion on aura des Navis des pardon des
avions pas des navires des avions qui
seront capables de pouvoir aller à la
Réunion les les Boeing triple 7 peuvent
le faire maintenant le Boeing l'Airbus
A330 c'est un peu plus compliqué en
termes d'autonomie mais on va avoir la
capacité demain de pouvoir toucher de
pouvoir toucher la Réunion et de pouvoir
être un acteur dans le fret dans le fret
aérien mais je suis pas assez
spécialiste pour répondre à votre
question sur sur la question de la
continuité territoriale et sur les aides
n'entend pas c'est bon
on ne t'entend plus Nassima
merci mais c'est vrai que quand on parle
du fret la question du prix reste malgré
tout la question qui intéresse
l'ensemble donc des usagers qui soient
commerçant
agriculteurs et même consommateurs donc
c'est vrai que c'est la question et vous
vous
avez bien fait de montrer que les
investissements étaient aussi
nécessaires ce qui explique que cela
voilà très bien non mais merci je
voulais en profiter madame la sénateur
je voulais en profiter ça c'est la
triste pardon je voulais vous voir en
profiter également pour vous remercier
pour ce que vous avez fait également la
réunion avec l'arrivée des portiques et
très content qu'il soit arrivé
et on sait qu'il y aura on sait on en
avait besoin ça a été ça a été difficile
pendant deux ans au niveau de
l'exploitation c'est aussi tout ça il y
a pas que le fret il y a également
comment également
ils peuvent ils peuvent accueillir ils
peuvent continuer à accueillir un navire
plus vert et un vire plus grand pour que
les frais de soient toujours compétitifs
et ça c'est fondamental c'est
fondamental dans notre réflexion c'est
tous ensemble
un port comme le port de La Réunion je
j'ai une petite adoration pour la
réunion je suis désolé parce que j'ai
vécu là-bas et j'ai été agent pour le
groupe là-bas c'est un port qui a
énormément de potentiel mais dans lequel
il faut il faut absolument être très
proche des autorités pour pour que les
travaux sur les caisses se passent bien
pour qu'on ait de l'espace sur les
terminaux pour pouvoir
fluidifier
la réception et la livraison aux clients
c'est tout un ensemble vous voyez et ce
que vous avez fait à la Réunion il faut
que il faut vraiment qu'on continue à le
faire sur d'autres ports également en
outre-mer on va le faire j'espère en
Martinique en Guadeloupe je sais qu'il y
a des grands projets
d'infrastructure qui sont nécessaires
pour nous pour on continue à se
développer et à accueillir ces grands
navires et être compétitif je pense à la
Réunion il y a Port-Louis qui est juste
à côté qui est qui veut accueillir
beaucoup plus de marchandises qui va
accueillir du transbordement il faut pas
vraiment oublier que on a quand même des
ports compétitifs dans les zones où on
est dans les outre-mer toujours et ça
c'est vraiment important que ça résonne
aussi
auprès des autorités parce que
aujourd'hui quand on escale en
République Dominicaine c'est des ports
qui se sont vite transformés qui vont
très vite qui attendent pas il y a des
investisseurs privés qui font que les
ports se développent rapidement et il
faut que nous avec nos ports et les
autorités on soit également proches les
uns les autres pour avoir les meilleurs
outils c'est très très important
merci avant de conclure je vais laisser
la parole à notre collègue Philippe
folio qui nous a rejoint
merci madame la Présidente je vous prie
de m'excuser parce que j'avais d'autres
d'autres contraintes et j'ai pas pu
écouter l'essentiel de ce que vous avez
dit mais je voudrais reprendre quelques
quelques éléments tout d'abord je pense
que pour la France et pour notre
économie bleue d'avoir un groupe comme
le vôtre c'est une grande chance et
c'est un atout assez exceptionnel
j'ai souvent coutume de dire la France
se croit à continental et européenne
alors qu'elle est mondiale et maritime
et vous vous êtes une expression de
cette mondialité et de cette maritimité
si je puis m'exprimer m'exprimer ainsi
ensuite je veux dire je voudrais revenir
sur un point que vous venez d'aborder et
pour faire suite à l'intervention de
Nassima concernant la Réunion et
notamment le port à la Réunion je pense
qu'il y a un élément qui est un élément
majeur par rapport à la Réunion c'est un
qui est situé sur des roues une route
commerciale qui est une route importante
et pleine de devenir ça c'est le premier
point et puis le deuxième point parce
qu'il y a quand même une difficulté dans
nos ports en général et dans nos ports
ultramarins en particulier c'est d'être
avec des espaces très contraints et avec
des difficultés de pouvoir développer
des activités portuaires par manque de
fonciers manque de place ce qui n'est
pas le cas la Réunion où il y a une
réserve foncière je veux dire tout à
fait majeur et importantes et donc dans
ce cadre là moi je voulais vous vous
posez une question excusez-moi je vais
être un peu un petit peu direct et vous
dire les choses telles que
tel que je voulais ça
on parle beaucoup de la problématique
des entreprises qui font des super
profits
et vous avez été ciblé j'allais dire par
rapport à ça et plutôt que d'aller vers
un schéma de taxation qui ne me semble
pas je le dis ça c'est un avis qui
n'engage que moi mais le plus opportun
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas moyen
d'essayer de travailler gagner en
gagnant entre CMA-CGM et j'ai dit non
collectivité territoriale
ultramarine pour essayer de les
accompagner dans la modernisation des
opérations de moins de leurs
infrastructures aéroportuaires et j'ai
entendu tout ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure au travers de votre volonté de
répondre aux nouvelles exigences de
l'Organisation maritime internationale
par rapport au fait d'être plus vertueux
en matière de défense de l'environnement
et on sait que jouer un rôle en rôle
important mais y compris j'allais dire
par rapport à des activités qui sont des
activités peut-être de
réparation ou d'entretien de vos
paquebots essayer de réfléchir sur tout
ce qui pourrait être créé qui
permettrait de développer de l'activité
dans nos outre-mer et dire voilà
effectivement
on a des profits importants on investit
comme vous venez de le dire dans si vous
me permettez l'expression le transport
vert mais que au-delà de ça on essaye de
faire quelque chose d'un petit peu
spécifique et particulier pour nos
desserts et nos pores
ultramarins ce qui serait un argument
que nous pourrions et les uns et les
autres mettre en avant au regard de ceux
qui vont dire non non mais on va
surtaxer etc etc
j'aurais représentant de Total je leur
dirai la même chose par rapport des
efforts qui pourraient faire en matière
de d'énergie verte et de développement
d'énergie renouvelable et je crois que
ça serait une approche qui me paraîtrait
plus intéressante plus consensuelle et
plus vertueuse et je le répète c'est un
enjeu majeur parce que tous nos
outre-mer en cette particularité c'est
d'être tous liés à la mer même si pas de
manière aussi
forte et profonde que ce qu'on pourrait
on pourrait espérer mais mais en ce sens
je crois que vous avez un
rôle et vous pourriez être des
facilitateurs si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi voilà excusez-moi madame la
Présidente d'avoir été un peu long mais
voilà
on est prêt
à étudier toutes les possibilités pour
pouvoir accompagner les territoires
par rapport au parliez des réparations
de navire pourquoi pas étudier alors
nous on n'est pas dans les paquebots
mais surtout les portes-conteneurs donc
tout ceci peut être étudié encore
faut-il que les pores soient équipés de
dry de port flottants par exemple pour
pouvoir réparer un navire on fait des
fois des interventions on a des on fait
du soutage également dans les
territoires d'outre-mer on saute
j'espère que demain on pourra sauter du
LNG dans ces territoires
voir mieux voir pourquoi pas développer
une industrie ensemble verte pourquoi
pas
on a un fond vert qui a été qui a été
initié par notre président de 1,5
milliards qui a été lancé maintenant il
y a plus de six mois
sur sur toute cette
possibilité de verdir qui est très
importante dans notre industrie mais pas
pas que et pourquoi pas demain essayer
de trouver des énergies renouvelables
c'est pas pourquoi pas la bagasse de la
canne à sucre qu'on puisse réutiliser et
qu'on puisse mettre à l'intérieur de nos
navires pour créer de la valeur dans vos
territoires on en est conscient
maintenant il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble il faut qu'on soit peut-être
qu'on pourra pas répondre à toutes
toutes les attentes mais je pense que
c'est important en tant que transporteur
maritime français et est en présence
fortement dans les territoires
ultramarins peut-être plus proche
des attentes locales et de travailler
plus maintenant la main on a fait pas
mal de
d'événements depuis depuis maintenant
pas mal d'années récemment monsieur et
kims parlait tout à l'heure
de l'investissement qu'on avait fait sur
toute la fondation
on va continuer évidemment
toutes les on a ouvert the box quand
même en Guadeloupe on fait des choses
localement je pense qu'il faut qu'on
continue il faut que ce soit encore plus
visible
et pourquoi pas la réponse en avale
pourquoi pas la formation je pense que
l'Académie aujourd'hui à Marseille qui
va être lancé demain à Marseille
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas la la
multiplier dans notre département
d'outre-mer il y a quand même zobox
aujourd'hui qui est un vrai incubateur
qui va j'espère permettre à des startups
de pouvoir de pouvoir progresser de
pouvoir amener de la valeur dans ces
territoires voilà je et on a on a
également cet engram ce
cette formation qui va ouvrir l'an
prochain je crois
sur sur Marseille mais oui vous avez
raison il faut qu'on travaille nos vins
dans la main pour créer cette valeur
dans nos territoires sur les territoires
je vous remercie pour cette optimiste et
cette volonté de travailler cette écoute
aussi à l'endroit des territoires
ultramarins je ne s'il y a pas d'autres
prises de parole je vais conclure en
vous remerciant tous d'avoir participé à
cette table ronde et
j'espère que nous allons poursuivre ces
travaux dans le cas de réunion comme là
aussi demandé notre rapporteur Madame
Catherine Cancun merci à tous et bonne
fin de journée merci au revoir au revoir